joining us now is former tennessee
congressman and fox news contributor
harold ford jr thank you for joining us
congressman i am not going to ask you to
defend policies that i don't think you
agree with um so let me ask you about
the politics the perception it does seem
the bib administration has been slow to
appreciate how americans feel about this
issue of crime but but i will give you a
chance to tell me if i'm wrong
well first off happy sunday thanks for
having me on i do think there's a
perception challenge that that my party
has around this issue i think we are
fortunate to have a very powerful
uh and significant voice in eric adams
here in my home city of new york where i
live and where my kids go to school
i think him being here the president
being here earlier last week
was was a was a positive thing not only
for him politically but i think
substantively now we should be we should
be honest about this the extremes on
both sides in each of our parties
unfortunately dominate and and frankly
are guiding too much of the conversation
eric adams presence is a welcome one
because in a refreshing one because i'm
hoping he can push through this but you
look at the left the defunding of the
police
the bell reform laws that frankly uh as
well-intentioned as they may have been
to ensure that non-violent offenders and
spend more time in jail for something
that had they even been convicted of
they may not have spent that much time
in is no excuse for not reforming those
laws in light of what we're dealing with
now defunding the police is one of the
dumbest ideas
dumbest political reactions i've heard
in the last 25 years and on the right
whenever we have gun violence it and we
we talk about ghost guns some on the
right are unwilling to even consider i
hear your point and i agree with you we
should prosecute uh and use the laws on
the books but we should have uh we
should be serious about this ghost gun
thing i think a little more than we are
so you have this negligence being
practiced on both sides but we should be
clear also democrats are the ones who
will face the greater
political liability heading into an
election season because of the list of
da's the list of the list of things that
the administration is or is not doing
i do think that again last week was
earlier last week was a positive for the
administration but they now have got to
act on it some of our new york press
here didn't think it was that big of a
deal the president coming i think the
new york post said blah blah blah was
their headline but at least there was a
visit and eric adams is certainly not
going to back down he in many ways is
the face of the democratic party when it
comes to how we're going to address
crime and the additional methods and for
that matter the reforms we're going to
make to some of the things that some in
our party have been saying for some time
around crime
all right congressman the president did
come and he did talk about ghost guns
and for people who are not steeped in
federal firearms that's a gun that's not
traceable either doesn't have a serial
number or it's been obliterated makes it
very hard to prosecute it when i was in
the house all of the rage was about
closing the gun show loophole and my
response is okay let's get tough on
ghost guns let's close the gun show
loophole
how many killings would that stop i mean
if ghost guns aren't aren't being used
in the crimes then you're talking about
something that is not the root of the
problem
why won't biden talk why won't he get
tough on progressive prosecutors why
won't he get tough on the d.a in los
angeles that's from a messaging
standpoint that's my question
i don't have a good answer to that to
that question trey i think
one of the things that if i if i were in
that white house we'd have fbi task
forces in chicago in los angeles and san
francisco uh here in new york as well
with men and women on the ground helping
the police
tracking these things and providing them
whatever resources they may need and
that should be that should be happening
uh look you know we we go back and forth
about the guns and the ghosts the ghost
guns and internet but one thing is clear
uh that the two officers that were
killed here last week that was a ghost
gun
that had been bought in philly
that that was used by that by that man
that they went into the house to because
his mom had called the police on them on
the police on him so i hear you and i
hope that the messaging in my party if
we don't get it right trey we're not
gonna we're not gonna fare well in this
election cycle it's a number two issue
on people's minds but i think it's the
number one issue in households all
across the country
congressman i hope he calls you he'll
find a really nice guy and a reasonable
voice on the other end of the phone if
the president calls you thank you for
joining us on a sunday night hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else